secondary worlds are fascinating it's no
surprise that were obsessed with them
that we want to explore them learn more
about how they work take a look at this
app Google Chrome made for the release
of The Hobbit films it's a hyper
realistic rendering of middle-earth far
from the sketches of Tolkien himself
farther still from the words he used to
describe it the chrome program can be
considered an act of world building an
extension of Tolkien's
own world building in the Lord of the
Rings and more intensely in The
Silmarillion there's something so
enchanting in the complexity of his
vision in its completeness in the
completeness of the languages and the
fact that they work it's impossible when
reading Lord of the Rings not to feel
that middle-earth is autonomous that it
exists despite your reading about these
days we have our pick of dense secondary
worlds fantasy literature is filled with
them think of the dune series or Narnia
or the late Terry Pratchett's Discworld
novels think of the race to fill in the
histories of Star Wars in books video
games in new films or take the secondary
world we're most obsessed with at the
moment the world of Westeros in George
RR Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire
none of these worlds are our own but
each is internally consistent and each
has developed audiences that hunger for
the author to fill in the margins the
gaps the geography the backstories the
histories and if the author won't
they'll do it themselves want to know
more about Khorasan or darth sidious
visit Wikipedia perhaps the most
exhaustive catalog of a secondary world
ever made why are we so consumed by
built worlds by the act of world
building is this a generous obsession or
a dangerous one the great science
fiction and fantasy writer M John
Harrison once famously called world
building the attempt to exhaustively
survey a place that isn't there
Harrison's point is that the world
building of much fantastic fiction which
takes Tolkien's legendarium as its
archetype shifts the focus of literature
away
the act which is most vital to its
usefulness the act of reading world
building in this view assumes a passive
reader it envisions a writer who
photographs a secondary world encodes it
into language and a reader who receives
this immersive experience like a film
blissfully and perhaps willingly unaware
that the world he experiences is a
rhetorical construct the only problem is
that all these assumptions are based on
false premises
you can't encode the world in language
readers are never passive they create
the text as much as a writer does and
all texts are rhetorical constructs in
other words writing is always a game
it's a transaction that emerges from a
writer's implications and a readers
interpretive toolbox world-building
fiction seems to deny this transaction
replace it with a cleaner way in which
the story on offer is like a clock and
the writer is like the clock maker the
problem is that this kind of fiction
creates a dependency in the reader to
know more to know everything I feel this
way all the time when I'm watching Game
of Thrones it's what sends me online
looking for backstories perhaps this is
why Harrison's own take on the fantasy
genre his great liriko Neum novels
resists so forcefully this urge for
dependency in varrock own 'i'm nothing
is ever the same twice from story to
story names change histories change
characters recur but it's never clear if
they're the same people you met before
like all books verrico Neum is just some
words says harrison there is no place no
society no dependable furniture to make
real you can't read it for that stuff so
you have to read it for everything else
everything else that's the bill of goods
the ideas and insights that spring forth
from the explosive act of reading the
for the record I think tokine did offer
that bill of goods he offered a poetic
utterance a metaphor it was the attempt
of those who came after two literal eyes
that metaphor and dilute its imagery by
asking things like but
did Sauron look like or just how might
an elf regiment organize itself it's
important to note that world building is
not exclusive to fantastic fiction it's
a staple of real world fiction as well
and indeed the real world its current
popularity is unsurprising given our
modern world which is its own kind of
fantasy indeed this is what makes
world-building so potentially dangerous
the world building of fiction only
greases the wheels for its much more
insidious and terrifying cousin
political world building the constructed
world presented to us by politics
marketing and the media the act of
narcissistic fantasy represented by the
word lore'l already exists well upstream
of JK Rowling or junior art okie neither
of them is anywhere near as successful
at world building as the geniuses who
devised coke or the Catholic Church I am
a huge fan of talking and Game of
Thrones and Star Wars but I'm also wary
and worried about a strain of passivity
in people that world building fiction
seems to at best reflect and at worst
encourage who we are is already hugely
and powerfully managed by interested
parties all around us maybe we ought at
least to seek out fiction fantastic or
otherwise that's a bit more impish and
challenging that demands our engagement
that rattles our perspective and exposes
the false fronts of the fantasy we were
born into the world that was built
without our consent hey everybody thanks
for watching if you want to support the
nerd writer and help me keep making
these videos you can go to my patreon
page at patreon.com slash nerd writer or
click Nantais here
can pledge as little as $1 anything and
everything helps you guys have been
amazing and slowly getting to that point
where I can do the nerd writer full-time
and that is the ultimate dream and I
think is the best way to get the best
content to you I just feel so creative
right now so many ideas and I just want
to I want to devote all my time to it so
that is
I you pledged if you pledged and I thank
you for it um some of the animations in
this video we're done by the amazing
channel life noggin this one right here
they're incredible so right now go to
their channel subscribe and watch the
videos I promise if you just watch one
you're what you want to subscribe
they're so great and they were awesome
for for doing this for me and we also
did a video for them so you can check
that out as well
I'll put the link in the description
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you guys next time